SENATE. COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WILL NOW COME TO
ORDER. WE ARE HOLDING OUR
HEARING TODAY IN ROOM 2200 OF
THE SWING SPACE. I ASK THAT ALL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE COME TO
THE HEARING ROOM. AND IT LOOKS
LIKE WE CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM
RIGHT NOW. SO WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN THE HEARING. BUT WE WANT
OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO MOSEY
ON DOWN. WE HAVE 17 MEASURES ON
TODAY'S AGENDA, ALL OF WHICH ARE
SUSPENSE CANDIDATES. ALL MEMBERS
OF WITH BILLS BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE HAVE WAIVED
PRESENTATION. BUT WE WILL TAKE
TESTIMONY FROM THE PUBLIC ON
EACH ITEM. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAS INDICATED THAT THEY
DO NOT HAVE A FILE ON ANY OF THE
MEASURES BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE,
AND THE REPRESENTATIVES WILL NOT
BE PRESENT TO TESTIFY. SO THIS
SHOULD MAKE THE HEARING GO
FAIRLY EXPEDITIOUSLY. BEFORE WE
BEGIN, I WANT TO REMIND ANY
WITNESSES TO LIMIT THEIR
TESTIMONY TO THE FISCAL ASPECTS
OF THE BILL. PLEASE REFRAIN FROM
LENGTHY POLICY DISCUSSIONS AND
REPEATING PRIOR TESTIMONY IN
YOUR COMMENTS. SO WE'RE GOING TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM AT THIS TIME,
MADAM ASSISTANT. ASSISTANT,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CABALLERO
HERE. CABALLERO HERE. JONES, I
AM HERE. JONES. HERE. ASHBY
BECKER. BRADFORD. BRADFORD HERE.
CIERTO CIERTO. HERE. WAHAB A
QUORUM HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED. SO
NOW WE CAN MOVE ON TO THE
BUSINESS OF THE DAY. WE'RE GOING
TO START WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE. IT IS SB 897. SENATOR
NEWMAN. AND THE SUBJECT IS PUPIL
ATTENDANCE INTERDISTRICT
ATTENDANCE. AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS
OF CHOICE. IS THERE ANYBODY WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL? I WANT TO INVITE
YOU TO PLEASE COME FORWARD. IS
THERE ANY SEEING? NO. NO ONE
APPROACHED THE MIC. IS THERE
ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB 897?
AND AGAIN, WE'RE HERE IN ROOM
2200, SEEING NO. ONE APPROACH
THE MIC. I WANT TO THANK ALL
THOSE WITNESSES THAT TESTIFIED.
AND THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE SB 897 TO
THE SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB 912 BY
SENATOR WIENER. COLORIMETRIC
FIELD DRUG TESTS. IS THERE
ANYBODY HERE IN ROOM 2200 WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
, SEEING NONE. IS THERE ANYBODY
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION? THÀNH SEEING
NONE. THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
SB 912 TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE, SB 969
BY SENATOR WIENER, ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES, ENTERTAINMENT ZONES
AND CONSUMPTION IS THERE ANYBODY
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IN ROOM
2200? SEEING NO ONE, WE'LL MOVE
ON TO OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE,
THIS AGAIN IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. WITHOUT OBJECTION,
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE IT TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE. I'M ASSUMING THAT
NO ONE WANTS TO SPEAK ON THESE
BILLS, AND THAT EVERYBODY REALLY
WOULD RATHER GO TO SEE THE
ECLIPSE. THERE'S LIKE TEN OF
THEM. I SEE NO ONE RAISING THEIR
HANDS. I DON'T SEE WELL, AND I,
I'M NOT LOOKING. SO NOBODY I
DON'T SEE ANYBODY. I'LL JUMP IN
WHEN I NEED TO. OKAY. SOUNDS
GOOD TIME. NEXT WEEK. THAT
SOUNDS GOOD. MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOUR, SB 927 BY
SENATOR DOLLY. INCOME TAX, GROSS
INCOME EXCLUSION. STATE OF
EMERGENCY. NATURAL DISASTER
SETTLEMENT. ANYBODY IN ROOM 2200
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. SEEING NO ACTIVITY. HOW
ABOUT IN OPPOSITION? SEEING
NONE. THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, WE WILL MOVE SB NINE,
927 TO THE SUSPENSE FILE. MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE, SB
953 BY SENATOR MENGIBAR MEDI-CAL
MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS PRODUCTS. IS
THERE ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL?
SEEING NO MOVEMENT, IS THERE
ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION? SEEING NO
ONE. THE BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE SB 953 TO THE SUSPENSE FILE
. MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIX. SB 1079 BY SENATOR MENGIBAR
YOUTH HOUSING BOND ACT OF 2024.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN ROOM
2200 THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? IS THERE ANYBODY
HERE AND SEEING NO MOVEMENT? IS
THERE ANYBODY HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION IN
SEEING. SEEING NO ONE APPROACH
THE MIC AGAIN, THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1079 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN, SB 958 BY SENATOR
DODD. SURPLUS STATE PROPERTY,
COUNTY OF NAPA. IS THERE ANYBODY
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL? IS
THERE ANYBODY IN ROOM 2200 THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NEITHER THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SB 958 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT. SB 971 BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
EXEMPTION FROM NONRESIDENT
TUITION FEE. RESIDENT OF A
REGION IMPACTED BY WAR OR
REGIONAL CONFLICT. CONFLICT IS
THERE ANYBODY IN ROOM 2200 THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
? SEEING NO ONE, IS THERE
ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION? SEEING NO
MOVEMENT. AGAIN, THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB 971 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE SB 980 BY SENATOR
WAHAB MEDI-CAL DENTAL CROWNS AND
IMPLANTS. IS THERE ANYBODY HERE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL? YES, MA'AM.
WELCOME. GOOD MORNING. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
CABALLERO AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS CINDY YOUNG, AND I'M
A VICE PRESIDENT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR
RETIREMENT AMERICANS. I'M ONE OF
THE STATE'S FOREMOST GRASSROOTS,
SENIOR AND DISABILITY
ORGANIZATIONS, REPRESENTING OVER
1 MILLION CALIFORNIANS. WE'RE
PROUD SPONSORS OF SB 980, THE
SMILE ACT, THE MOST RECENT
PUBLICATION FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES MANAGER
MENDOCINE MEDI-CAL MONTHLY
ELIGIBLE FAST FACTS, DATED
JANUARY 2023, REPORTS THAT THERE
ARE 1.68 MILLION DUAL ELIGIBLE
SENIORS AND ABOUT 711,000
SENIORS AND PERSONS WITH
DISABILITY PARTICIPATING IN THE
MEDI-CAL PROGRAM. SINGLE TOOTH
IMPLANTS ARE NOT A COVERED
BENEFIT UNDER THE DENTAL
MEDI-CAL PROGRAM UNLESS THERE IS
AN EXCEPTIONAL MEDICAL CONDITION
LIKE CANCER, SEVERE LOSS OF
UPPER JAW BONE, SKELETAL
DEFORMITIES, OR TRÊN, OR THE
TRAUMATIC JAW DECONSTRUCTION OF
THE JAW. WHEN A TOOTH IS LOST,
THE ABSENCE AFFECTS MORE THAN
JUST THE VISIBLE GAP BENEATH THE
SURFACE. THE JAWBONE REQUIRES
REGULAR STIMULATION FROM TEETH
TO MAINTAIN ITS DENSITY AND
HEALTH. WITHOUT THE STIMULATION,
THE BONE BEGINS ATROPHY, LEADING
TO A CONDITION KNOWN AS
RESORPTION. THE WEAKENING OF THE
JAW BONE CAN ALTER FACIAL
STRUCTURE, POTENTIALLY LEADING
TO FURTHER LOSS AND IMPACT.
SPEECH AND HEARING. WHILE THIS
IS A DIFFICULT BUDGET YEAR, THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THE MEDI-CAL
POPULATION NOT GETTING THESE
NEEDED SERVICES WILL LEAD TO
GREATER COST TO THE STATE AND TO
TREATMENT AND TO TREAT DECLINING
HEALTH AS A RESULT OF POOR ORAL
HEALTH TREATMENT AND IS NOT
COVERED BY MEDI-CAL. WE ASK THAT
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CONSIDER THE DIRE NEED
FOR SB 980 AND RELEASE THE BILL
FROM THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? AGAIN, ON THE FISCAL
IMPACTS. THANK YOU. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. JOE SAENZ WITH THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION, REPRESENTING LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? VERY
GOOD. WE'LL MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION. IS THERE ANYBODY
HERE THAT WANTS TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB 980? SEEING NO
ONE. THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 980 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TEN, SB 892 BY SENATOR
WAHAB. CRIMES. ORGANIZE THEFT.
IS THERE ANYBODY IN ROOM 2200
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT? GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR CHRIS MCCAULEY. ON BEHALF
OF THE LOS ANGELES AREA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I'M
SORRY. THIS IS 982. SO, YES, A
CELEBRITY IN OUR POLICE. ÁP
MINUTE. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
GOOD MORNING TO YOU. HAPPY
MONDAY, ANDREW ANTWI, ON BEHALF
OF THE LOS ANGELES CITY
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE, WE FILED A
LETTER OF SUPPORTS ON THE RECORD
AND THE SCOURGE OF ORGANIZED
RETAIL THEFT. ALSO OFTEN HAPPENS
IN THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES AND
THROUGH GREATER LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND OTHER URBANIZED AREAS
OF THE STATE. WE THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE TO REMOVE THE SUNSET
DATE FROM THE STATUTE THAT
ESTABLISHED THIS ENTITY, AND WE
THANK THE COMMITTEE AND HOPE
THAT THE BILL IS RELEASED FROM
SUSPENSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN IN SUPPORT?
MOVING ON TO OPPOSITION. IS
THERE ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION IN
ROOM 2200 ON SB 982, SEEING NO
OPPOSITION. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 982 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER 11, SB 1004 BY
SENATOR WILK. INCOME TAXES,
EXCLUSIONS AND WILDFIRES IS
THERE ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 1004?
IS THERE ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE
TO FILE IN OPPOSITION AND
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION? SEEING
NONE THE THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATES. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION. SB 1004 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO SB FILE
ITEM NUMBER 12. SB 1023 BY
SENATOR WILK, CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY, ANTELOPE VALLEY OR
VICTOR VALLEY CAMPUS. IS THERE
ANY ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL?
SEEING NO ONE, IS THERE ANYBODY
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? SB 1023 IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CABINET CANDIDATE.
SO WITHOUT OBJECTION, WE WILL
MOVE THIS TO THE SUSPENSE FILE.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
13, SB 1028 BY SENATOR ALVARADO
GILL. ALCOHOL BEVERAGE LICENSES
ON SALE. GENERAL LICENSES FOR
BONA FIDE EATING PLACES. IS
THERE ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 1028?
IS THERE ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION? AGAIN,
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE SEEING NO TESTIMONY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION, WE WILL MOVE
THIS TO THE SUSPENSE FILE.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
14, SB 1023 BY SENATOR PADILLA.
HOUSING FINANCE PORTFOLIO
RESTRUCTURING. LOAN FORGIVENESS.
IS THERE ANYONE IN ROOM 2200
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? IS THERE ANYONE IN ROOM
2200 THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION? SEEING NEITHER
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. AND SO, WITHOUT
OBJECTION, WE WILL MOVE THIS TO
THE SUSPENSE FILE. MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER 15, SB 1309 BY
SENATOR PADILLA. LITHIUM BATTERY
PRODUCTION COUNCIL. IS THERE
ANYONE IN ROOM 2200 THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT?
SEEING NO MOVEMENT, IS THERE
ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION? SEEING NO
TESTIMONY WITH THE BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CABINET CANDIDATE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1309 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
SB 1130 BY SENATOR BRADFORD.
ELECTRICITY FAMILY ELECTRIC RATE
ASSISTANCE AND REPORTS. IS THERE
ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? I'LL TESTIFY
ON THAT. YOU'LL SEE. SINCE SINCE
YOU WAIVED PRESENTATION, WE'RE
VERY, VERY HAPPY WITH THAT. SEE,
SEEING NO ONE IN SUPPORT, IS
THERE ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION? I MIGHT
DO I GO UP TO THE MIC UP THERE?
YES. YES, I CAN. OKAY. SEEING NO
ONE FROM THE AUDIENCE THAT WANTS
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION, THIS IS
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1130 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AND THEN THE FINAL BILL TODAY IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER 17, SB 1341 BY
SENATOR ALLEN. PUPIL INSTRUCTION
. COURSE OF STUDY. VISUAL AND
PERFORMING ARTS. MEDIA ARTS. IS
THERE ANYBODY IN ROOM 2200 THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
? SEEING NONE, IS THERE ANYBODY
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NEITHER THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SB 1341 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
WELL, THAT WAS EXPEDITIOUS.
DONE. THANK YOU TO EVERYBODY ON
THE COMMITTEE. MUCH BETTER THAN
THE FORMER CHAIR. THE PROBLEM
IS, WE DON'T HAVE ANY OF THOSE
QUESTIONS. THE TRIVIA QUESTIONS
ARE YES. NO, BUT YOU KNOW, I'VE
GOT I'VE GOT SOME. AND YOU KNOW,
WE NEED TO GET OUT AND SEE THE
SOLAR ECLIPSE. SO. ALL RIGHT, I
KNOW BRADFORD SHOWN UP YET SO
SHE WOULDN'T BE RECORDED.
SENATOR BECKER IS ABSENT TODAY,
SO I DON'T KNOW IF WE'RE GOING
TO TRY AND GET HER HERE SO SHE
CAN. SO THEY HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE
TO REACH HER OFFICE. OKAY
ANYWAY. YEAH, SHE'S SHE'S ON HER
WAY NOW. SO.
WE'RE WAITING FOR ONE MORE
MEMBER TO ADD ON. SO THIS IS THE
END OF THE AGENDA, SO I WANT TO
THANK EVERYBODY FOR BEING HERE
ON TIME AND READY TO ROLL. AND
WE'LL JUST WAIT A FEW MINUTES
.
SO I'D LIKE TO THANK EVERYBODY
FOR PARTICIPATING IN TODAY'S
HEARING. WE HAVE NOW CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA AND THE MEETING OF
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS IS ADJOURNED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE